when you're 20 years old and all of a
sudden you're the heavyweight champion
the world just a few years ago you were
poor and now all the sudden you're the
king of the world
that's really crazy you know it's really
crazy that I wasn't able to handle
I wouldn't expect in that that was a
really [ __ ] punch right there
Charlie Murphy told us a story and it's
animated it's on YouTube now of you and
him coming over your house in a
limousine and you Ella it was a lion or
a tiger tiger beam I throw the line for
the tiger dude it is one of the craziest
[ __ ] stories I always when surfer
people who don't know I got to hang out
with you at one of my shows one time and
it was a great I had the best time
talking about everything what made you
think you could get a tiger and so I'm
in prison at the time so I'm in prison
I'm talking to my car dealer at the time
and he has a he has some cars to belong
to a friend of mine that suppose a
friend of ours and he's discussing the
fee doesn't pay for these cars imma sell
these cars to someone and get some
horses horses lions tigers I got exactly
you do can you get me some tigers yeah
the guy told me man how cool that baby
because I had a bunch of fans because
man that man you be in the Aston Martin
or Ferrari every that would be cool
right yeah get me some cosmic then when
I came home I had those Cubs right there
waiting for me so you raised them as
Cubs yeah that's that's how you were
because I would see footage of you like
[ __ ] smacking them around and jumping
on one of your tires and I was like holy
[ __ ] and I had within their bag that
their mother the mother their baby now
never gets this is a crazy picture you
and your underwear with a tiger on chain
that is that is one of the that's the
dance right there
that's you a peak crazy yeah insane yeah
what's going through my mind
know what made me think about my friends
and Mike you can get some awesome
animals I'm gonna get from hot Oh
everybody does it though
those are things about uh with what's
his face from narcos Oh Pablo Escobar
you got like a [ __ ] zoo yeah they all
do it don't you get like that rich
you're like just get some Adam rich
people they snuck in that's right Jack
my head Oh F that's right
Michael Jackson yeah they had like a zoo
in his back that's true
yeah that weird [ __ ] like weird Birds
yeah I don't think it may be out of
monkey or something he did have weird
okay nothing Dane
hung up there before at the Playboy
Mansion this is at the end of his career
if I can well the ten years ago
something that was pretty awesome yeah
that guy man what a life he lived you
yeah
pajamas there's balls and he's 80 and
[ __ ] oh no deep into his age yeah his
90s
yeah it's yeah he'd be really here's the
thing that dude lived the lifestyle he
was talking about you know a lot of
people talk [ __ ] yeah you don't really
do that he was really dunno I thought be
dark I forgetting dark you have too much
yeah to play one others